"THE FIVE" COMING UP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REVEALED PLANS
FOR THE NATIONAL INDEPENDENCE
DAY PARADE.
IT'S GOING TO BE FIERCE.
YOU HAVE MUSIC, FLYOVERS,
FIREWORKS.
TANKS.
LOTS OF TANKS.
PLUS, A SPEAK BY TRUMP HIMSELF.
ME, I DON'T LIKE PARADES.
FOR ME, IT'S JUST THE BACKS OF
PEOPLE'S NECKS.
BUT YOU CAN SET YOUR WATCH TO
THE MEDIA RESPONSE.
>> WHAT IS THE MESSAGE THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO SEND?
WHO IS THAT MESSAGE TO?
IT'S NOT THE TYRANTS.
HE LIKES TYRANTS.
HE LOVES THEM.
IT'S NOT PUTIN, KIM JONG-UN OR
THE SAUDIS.
IS IT TO OUR FRIENDS?
WESTERN DEMOCRACY OR TO US?
THE RESISTANCE IN THIS COUNTRY?
I HAVE TANKS.
I HAVE THIS MILITARY ARMADA.
THE MESSAGE IS A THREAT.
DONALD TRUMP STYLES HIMSELF A
TYRANT, NOT A DEFEATER OF
TYRANTS.
>> THIS IS NAUSEATING, CHRIS.
THIS IS NOT JUST OBNOXIOUS, THIS
IS DANGEROUS.
IT'S UN-AMERICAN.
CLEARLY DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO
TRAN MITT A MESSAGE OF HIS
STRENGTH BECAUSE HE PERCEIVING
HIMSELF A BEING WEAK AROUND THE
WORLD, WHICH HE IS.
>> IT WAS ABOUT BOLSTERING
HIMSELF UP.
LOOKING LIKE A DICTATOR FROM
ANOTHER NATION OR A TIME THAT
FORGOT.
>> THE SELF-SATISFIED OUTRAGE.
THE SCORN THAT YOU FINDS.
HOW CAN YOU SALUTE SOMETHING SO
ROTTEN?
THE RESPONSE TO MEDIA THAT
ALIGNS THEM, IT'S A SAFE BET
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT HEAPING
LOADS OF RID YOU'LL ON A JULY
FOURTH RAID ARE HEAPING PRAISE
ON COLIN KAEPERNICK.
IT'S THE SAME MOCKERY FOR TRUMP.
IT'S THE SAME SCORN AGAINST YOU
AND ME AND NOT TO SEE THE EDGES
OF LOVING YOUR DOWN TRY.
I'M SURE SOME HOPE THAT THE
PARADE IS A FLOP, A DISASTER.
NOT ME AND CERTAINLY NOT YOU.
YOU MAY NOT NEED A PARADE OR
WANT ONE BUT YOU'RE GETTING ONE.
BECAUSE THIS OLD GUY THAT LOVES
THIS COUNTRY BECAME PRESIDENT
AND THIS WAS ON HIS LIST.
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN ON
YOURS, TOO.
JUAN, YOU TOLD ME HOW MUCH YOU
HAD A AMERICA.
YOU HATE AMERICA SO MUCH THAT
YOU HAD A THIS PARADE.
YOU DIDN'T SAY THAT.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID IT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
BEAT ME UP.
I HAVE TO SAY, I HAPPEN TO AGREE
WITH MUCH OF WHAT YOU PLAYED IN
THAT MONTAGE.
TO ME --
>> WE'RE NOT SURPRISED, JUAN.
>> I LOVE PARADES AND I LOVE THE
FOURTH OF JULY AND I LOVE
AMERICA.
I DON'T THINK WHAT TRUMP IS
DOING IS ABOUT AMERICA.
IT'S ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HIS POLITICIZED THIS EVENT.
NOW THEY HAVE THAT BABY TRUMP
BALLOON WILL BE ON THE MALL.
THEY HAVE TRUMP SITTING ON THE
POT ON THE MALL.
I'M LIKE WHY WOULD ANYONE TURN
THE FOURTH OF JULY INTO A POLL
-- POLARIZING --
>> HE'S NOT POLARIZING ANYTHING.
YOU GUYS ARE.
IF YOU HAVE A CELEBRATION OF OUR
AMERICAN MILITARY AND YOU HAVE
F-22s AND ABRAMS TANKS, AND IF
YOU GUYS ON THE LEFT ARE
OFFENDED BY THAT AND YOU THINK
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS GOING TO ROLL THE
TANKS OVER THE RESISTANCE
BECAUSE HE THINKS IT'S TIANANMEN
SQUARE, YOU'RE THE ONES
POLITICIZING THE EVENT.
HE'S SHOWING TO SHOW
ALL THE HARDWARE WE BOUGHT.
TRYING TO CELEBRATE AMERICA.
>> WHY IS HE THE WHITE HOUSE
HANDING OUT TICKETS TO A SELECT
SECTION FOR HIS BIGGEST
SUPPORTERS?
WHY IS THAT?
>> WHY WOULDN'T HE?
>> IT'S A POLITICAL EVENT.
>> EVERY EVENT IS A POLITICAL
EVENT WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS THERE.
IF A DEMOCRAT DID THIS, WHICH
THEY HAVE DONE, J.F.K. DID IT,
THEY DID IT THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
I'M SURE HE HANDED OUT TICKETS
TO HIS BUDDIES.
>> DAGEN, IF THE BIG PROBLEM
HERE IS HANDING OUT TICKETS, THE
COUNTRY IS GOING PRETTY GOOD.
IF THAT'S THE BIG STORY TODAY.
>> YOU KNOW HOW GOOD IT'S GOING?
IT'S FREE.
YOU CAN GO TO D.C. AND SEE THE
FIREWORKS WHICH WAS DONATED,
$750,000 FROM TWO FIREWORKS
COMPANIES INCLUDING PHANTOM,
$750,000 FREE.
15 MINUTE FIREWORKS SHOW, 19,000
DEVICES.
THEY HAVE THIS EXCLUSIVE PIXEL
BURSTING AMERICAN FLAG THAT WILL
BE 700 FEET WIDE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT UNFURL AND NOT
HAVE TO LAY EYES ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
CAN I JUST SAY I FIND IT
HILARIOUS WATCHING THESE
MONTAGES OF THE HUFFS AND
PUFFING MEDIA.
THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TAKEN UP
RESIDENCE IN THEIR HEAD.
THAT HE IS THEIR SUN.
THEY CAN'T GET OUT OF BED UNLESS
HE'S UP TWEETING ALREADY BECAUSE
HE GIVES THEM LIGHT.
HE'S TURNED THEM INTO RANTING
AND RAVING LUNATICS THAT HATE
FIREWORKS AND THE FOURTH OF
JULY.
ALL RIGHT?
>> WHICH IS CRAZY.
IT'S ABOUT THE MILITARY, RIGHT?
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
SAY WE TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
THE MILITARY IS, HOW THEY LOVE
OUR TROOPS AND VETERANS.
AND YET THE COMPLAINTS ARE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE TANKS, THE
TOOLS OF THE TRADES THAT WE
NEVER SEE THAT KEEP THIS NATION
SAFE, THAT ALLOW US TO ENJOY
LIFE EVERY DAY, NOT JUST THE
FOURTH OF JULY BUT THE NATURE --
IT'S NOT JUST YOU SIGN UP FOR
THE MILITARY.
YOU GO AND TRAIN TO FIRE THAT
WEAPON.
YOU TRAIN TO RUN THE TANK.
YOU'RE A PILOT.
IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE HOPING AND
WISHING THAT WE KEEP THE NATION
SAFE.
PEOPLE DO THAT.
IT'S A CELEBRATION OF THEM.
THAT'S WHAT AMERICA SEES.
IT'S LIKE WHY YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE MILITARY AND THE TOOLS
OF THE TRADE?
>> IT'S NOT A CELEBRATION OF THE
MILITARY.
THE CHIEFS WON'T EVEN BE THERE
FOR JUST THAT REASON.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> THAT'S NOT FOR JUST THAT
REASON.
THEY HAD --
>> THE CHAIRMAN OF THE --
>> IT'S NOT THE CHAIRMAN.
IT'S THE PRESIDENT THAT GOT OUT
OF MILITARY SERVICE WITH BONE
SPURS.
>> YOU HAVE TO GO TO THAT TO
SUPPORT YOUR ARGUMENT?
>> AT LEAST HE'S MAKING UP FOR
WHAT PEOPLE COMPLAIN ABOUT IN
THE PAST.
WHATEVER HE'S DONE TILL NOW,
HE'S CHANGED THE TRAJECTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY AND ALL OF OUR
LIVES AND THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH.
>> I HAVE A THEORY THAT THE
MEDIA HATES THIS BECAUSE IT'S
NOT FOR THEM.
IT'S FOR THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS ACTUALLY -- THE FOURTH
OF JULY PARADE IS REVERSE HOFF
THE CORRESPONDENT'S DINNER.
FOR TWO WEEKS, THREE WEEKS, YOU
HEAR ABOUT THE CORRESPONDENT'S
DINNER.
THEY CAN'T WAIT.
NOBODY CARES.
>> IT'S EMBARRASSING FOR THEM.
IN THE LONG RUN, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HEAR THAT AND THIS IS A
WORRY FOR LIBERALS.
MOST LIBERALS LOVE THE MILITARY
AND LOVE THE COUNTRY AND MAKES
NO SENSE WHAT THE MEDIA HAS SAID
ABOUT IT.
WHAT IS NOT TO LOVE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY?
WE'RE FABULOUS.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS IS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP --
>> IT IS IF YOU ARE WEARING
TRUMP GLASSES.
YOU'RE WEARING TRUMP GLASSES.
>> TURNING THE FOURTH OF JULY
INTO A TRUMP CAMPAIGN RALLY AND
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S ABOUT THE
MILITARY.
>> IT'S ABOUT THE NATION.
IT'S ABOUT THE FOURTH OF JULY.
HE HAPPENS TO BE THE PRESIDENT.
HOW GREAT FOR US IS THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT YOUR BANK ACCOUNT.
>> IT WAS GEORGE CONWAY, KELLY
AN'S HUSBAND --
>> YOU'RE GOING TO QUOTE HIM?
>> INSECURITY SPEAKS LOUDLY LIKE
THIS.
TO YOUR POINT, DAGEN, ABOUT
MONEY, WHY IS THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE GIVING US TWO MILLION OR
THREE MILLION --
>> YOU'RE COMPLAINING ABOUT $2
MYSTERIOUS AL YOU PROPOSED A
$100 TRILLION GREEN NEW DEAL.
REALLY?